[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces personnels qui sont retrouvés du
jour au lendemain sans 100 entrées
d'argent
notre travail et nous avec elles c'est
qu'elles ne cèdent pas aux appels de
quelques clients parfois pas ce qu'est
ce que ses clients la hausse y en a qui
en profitent sont de ce moment-là de
faiblesse de précarité pour nous c'est
devenu très complexe parce que qu aucun
revenu ne rentre je peux pas me
permettre d'aller travailler au bois
avec les risques que ça en cours
[Musique]
je perds franchement je trop peur de
taper la maladie coville a entraîné
aussi une espèce d obligations d aller à
vivre le travail du sexe dans le déni
c'est à dire presque obligé à mentir à
mentir à des associations peut-être
comme la nôtre qui avait crié avant le
coup vide
toutes ont une relation de confiance
pour parler ouvertement de sexualité des
prises de risques des préventions de là
alors à lancé moore y a rien fait contre
barbare
j'exige je voudrais pas revenir mais il
faut manger du cher
les tpe qui sont dans une situation
extrêmement difficile maintenant c'est
parce qu'auparavant elles ont déjà été
abîmée et fragilisé par la loi
[Musique]